was the last time I went to the doctor I
don't know but we just text now
me and the doc we just send pics now
what do you think of my boner dude
yo doc yo monthly check-in everything's
still good with my boner how's this [__]
hanging what do you think has this grown
at all uh your erection still looks fine
Cody
all right for show my doctor called me
yesterday he's like yeah by the way I'm
moving on from the office and have a
good life basically and I was like no
dude what what are you gonna do and he's
like oh I'm thinking about uh maybe some
content and I was like oh Dr Mike type
[__] huh and he was like maybe something
like that I was like well you know I'm a
YouTuber so if you ever need any advice
or anything like that and he's like I
know I've seen your dick and I've seen
your videos this first video I've seen
Cody Coast nuts uh Dr Dave here
um they're this big
for his very first video ever exposing
kodako's actual dick size he's like it's
not very big and he just pulls his nuts
out but this [__] is look at this